as your dad caught you jacking off
are you talking to me or him
that's actually a good question I think
both of us are going to have a different
answer I think I'm gonna say no because
I don't think I've ever been caught you
might have an answer of you might have
walked in on it and I didn't see you
here's what's even worse it wasn't me it
was your mom
what
room
Dwight shut the door and she goes I'm
never going in his room again
and right away I was like oh he was
jerking off huh she was like how'd you
know I'm like that's the only thing that
would elicit
yeah well that's a bummer I've never
caught him jerking off uh but my wife
has and um sorry yeah
I'm not that's funny I like it